well guys
you have picked the coolest independent
activities period
class you could ever do with ground
school this is the most awesome thing
possible when i saw the course offerings
so kudos to tina and phil for teaching
this this is a good
good gig i go by laz it's a fighter
pilot thing
all fighter pilots have call signs
they're not like what you see in the
movies by the way top gun is the worst
movie for any fighter pilot to watch
it's terrible
drives you crazy no one is called
maverick because they're the most
awesome thing on the face of the planet
never happens that way
you're always named for something silly
so the previous discussion about
crew resource management if you're
single seat you still have air traffic
control you have other guys
i am living proof that that's 100 true
so i won't get into it too much but
suffice to say if you know the biblical
story of lazarus you know a lot about
how i got my name
and i'll leave it at that normally
that's over beer afterwards
so we're here to talk about f 22 flight
control stuff i'm going to give you the
the punch line right at the start
i'm here to tell you that everything
you're learning so who's actually flown
airplanes here already
like cell planes so a lot of guys right
so a lot of guys so first time then for
probably the other half of the class or
so
so here's what i'm here to tell you the
same stuff that you're learning with
respect to cessna's
and all the stuff with respect to the
ground school
there's no difference between this and
between my beloved raptor it's the same
thing
so there's great relevance and you as
mit guys have the ability to derive and
figure out what makes
the raptor look the way that it does and
we can talk a lot about the flight
controls it's not
cosmic we can go through that so with
that
they always have the standard personal
background slide here's here's a gig
i'll keep it really simple i am a test
pilot
which means i am a fighter pilot and i'm
also an engineer
it means i like beavis and butthead
greatly and i read carl sagan it's the
same thing to me
so as a fighter test pilot you live in
the world of being a fighter pilot
but you also have the ability to
understand matlab and to be able to do
cool neat mit-ish kind of things because
all of the stuff that you're working
with as a test pilot
are brand new things new weapons new
avionics new airplanes in some cases
and that's not the world of a fighter
pilot fighter pilots are exceptionally
good at taking this airplane to combat
and doing the normal kind of missions
with it but when there's something new
on board
that requires an engineer so i have a
deep deep connection with this
institution i graduated here finished up
here last year in 2018
having a whole bunch of other kind of
funky stuff along the way
two combat tours that was a lot of fun
i'll tell you flying is one of my great
passions flying and getting shot at
and missed is my second great passion
that's much cooler
um and then when you can fly and you can
use that airplane to actually protect
people from bad guys that's that's
that's life fulfilling right to go get a
chance to go do that so we can talk a
little bit more through that as well
test pilot we get a chance to fly a lot
of different stuff so you'll see this
76 different airplanes that might sound
weird to kind of the rest of the world
but in the world of flight tests that's
pretty normal
and the reason that's there is it's just
like like so
i by the way warning right to the class
i talk a lot in terms of movies right
game of thrones shows whatever
television shows and sports
because no matter where you come from
those three topics always tend to bring
everybody
all together so it is just like what
you've you know when you've gone car
shopping
and you sit in this car and go oh man i
really like this way the steering wheel
feels but i hate the way the radio
is set up and you go to another car and
you go oh man this is great from a
you know from the sunroof whatever but
this stinks uh that same kind of
discernment that you have when you're
shopping for cars you know
this airplane is a couple hundred
million dollars you don't want to be
wrong about that and so you want your
test pilots very very experienced in a
lot of different airplanes
so i've got a chance to fly helicopters
they're spectacular in pilot training i
don't know why but we send our worst
pilot training students to helicopters
it's the dumbest idea because
helicopters are really really
challenging to go fly
but we've had a chance to fly
helicopters your discussion tina earlier
about right away i was laughing with
that because i've flown a zeppelin
an airship it's quite spectacular it's a
big lazy boy couch
with a big trim wheel and big engines
that actually pivot on the outside so
you can turn the whole
ship based on that that's pretty normal
for for being a test pilot is getting a
chance to fly a lot of different
airplanes more so than just one
particular airplane your whole life
most of my stuff is in fighters so i've
flown every frontline fighter with the
exception of the f-35
hopefully i'll fix that soon shortly in
a few months
um but a lot of stuff so mit guy harvard
guy
did some stuff it's it's been a good
life really at the end of the day what i
want to impress on you
is i am 100 zero different from anybody
in this room i just have more battle
scars on me just from a lifetime of
doing this
uh i started off flying cessna i did
that for several years of my life i
still do it i
love it fly sail planes still do it love
it
and all the stuff that you learn with
this has direct applicability to the
more
advanced fighter airplanes in fact i'll
tell you this
is actually harder to fly than the
raptor
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that as we go through all right so more
fun and games
all right so now comes the class
participation part uh my my talks are
very interactive
i love kind of hearing what you guys
think so we'll do a quick thought
exercise i'll try and keep a mental note
because i stink at writing on a
chalkboard
but we'll chat through this just so you
can understand that there's really not
that much difference from what you're
learning now
to go off to do something like that so
why does a cessna
look the way that it does and why does a
raptor
look the way that it does what were the
engineers trying to do
and just just call them out you know
real god just shoot
that right here okay so explain um you
have um way more area that's clear
the wings are swept in back and i kind
of do all yours with that so we can go
yeah see all around here so you've
brought up two things one is the
position of the wings right so in a
cessna
uh the wings are obviously well in a lot
of airplanes really not just cessnas but
in the cessna the wings are directly
above you big hershey bar wing you know
why do they put the wings this way in a
cessna
you're doing great so far keep going man
i'm i'm gonna answer that
uh get get in or out of a cirrus in the
heavy rain and you will immediately see
the value of that cessna wing yeah they
did this so that my wife doesn't yell at
me in bad weather conditions so that you
can
get inside the airplane without getting
completely wet the other part about the
high wing is it's great for visibility
looking
down right where this is terrible is if
you're turning
and you have to be able to see through
the wing because you're kind of doing
the old you know looking over the side
to see
kind of out the outside so that's one
advantage right of where raptor right
it's not a high wing or
it's kind of like a mid wing if you will
but that wing is well after the cockpit
for what reason
visibility yep that's that's the big
huge reason why and then you also
brought up the idea of the swept wings
all right uh why the swept wings
compared to
say straight wings
okay what's that what's what's that
advantage um something that um
i'll stop picking you because you're
bold and went first go ahead
yeah mock so explain mock uh
fast closer you get to the speed of
sound more compressibility is important
yep uh aerodynamically the wing really
behaves
like it's going at the speed normal to
the leading edge yeah so
you ever see those old like the first
jet airplanes that came out
um the wings on the jet airplanes had
wings that looked exactly like this
and that was a problem i'm going to do
something i thought i wouldn't try to do
but i'll try to do it so here's your
swept wing right
here's the air as it comes over the wing
right and then what ends up happening is
really what you care about
is the air that's going over top of the
wing that's
normal to the cord line of the wing
itself you know what i mean when i say
cord
right just like this imaginary line so
on a hershey bar wing all of that air
hits the wing
and it goes directly over top of that
cord line of the wing so
like when we talked about over here the
wings have camber
so what happens to the air as it goes
over top of
any wing doesn't matter if it's a
fighter wing or whatever else but what
happens to the velocity of the air as it
goes over top
it goes faster right so if i'm already
going fast and air hits my wing and goes
over top of my wing and goes faster than
the rest of the airplane
that's going to cause a problem when you
get to very high speeds approaching mach
because what ends up happening is you'll
get a shock wave forming on that wing
and the moment you get a shock wave form
in there that's like a big brick wall
to the to the wind and that causes all
types of drag downstream slows down the
airplane all types of things
so what they found is i can sweep the
wing right when i sweep the wing
some of that air is normal to the cord
line so if this is like the fuselage
over here and here's the wing and it
comes back over here
some of that air is going to be that way
and some of that air is going to
actually go out and go
go span wise if you will like this so
i'm trying to draw this correctly to get
the
to get the right angles but you kind of
get my point so
some of that air goes span wise some of
the reasons why you have wing winglets
right to present
prevent some of that drag that happens
at the winglets but then also what
you're worried about is rather than the
full component of this wind you're only
worrying about the wind
that's normal to the flow of the way the
cord line is set up so that's why they
sweep the wings right
okay so what else why does the cessna
look this way why does this look like
that okay
yeah good both
okay so stealth payload is an important
thing let's talk about the payload for a
second
actually we'll talk about stealth since
you brought it up um so look at that
plan
form and what do you notice with regards
to stealth
all angles right that angle that angle
that angle yeah no right angles
so the reason is and i'll do
my high tech pizza you know aid here
right
so who's who's doubly in here anyone
double e for mit okay
so if you're a beam of radar energy you
love this
right you love when you have a nice flat
thing directly to reflect so all that
radar energy you put at me
goes right back at you right now what
happens if i take that
panel and i go like this a little bit
right so
yeah there's not so much now i'll really
mess with your mind what happens if i do
that right now you have to start dealing
with angles and edges right
raptor is this constant fight between
the double e
guys and the aeronautical engineers when
you make an airplane like this and you
make angles like this and you make it
there's no right angles or whatever else
like that you're exactly right it
greatly reduces the stealth
now this is not wonder woman's airplane
it's not like you just become invisible
and no one can see you
but it's very very hard to see on radar
but there's a challenge in that because
when you make an airplane that looks
like this
which the double e guys tend to like the
aero engineer guys
tend to hate because it makes the
airplane unstable
so we'll talk about that this airplane
very very stable
very very stable okay what else couple
other things so why does the raptor look
this way
why does a cessna look this way
good uh i feel like the cessna is
designed to be produced with
cheap commodity materials yep the raptor
uses exotic metals
titanium whole types of stuff right so
this is an airplane people buy
commercially if you had if you were jeff
bezos you would never purchase this
airplane
because it is hyper expensive um my jets
were
test jets uh which means they were very
different almost like hand-built custom
f-22s
each one three to four hundred million
dollars a piece
uh scary all right in terms of how much
it actually costs
the canopy on this thing probably worth
more than about 10 of these
kind of all put together the payload
part you brought a payload too so the
other part about the stealth
if you can see here i've got doors so
there's a big main weapon bay door big
17 foot doors if you will and then
there's doors on the side that come up
in here
unlike a cessna i mean we talked about
you can where tina go oh she disappeared
the dropped object dropping pumpkins my
pumpkins are a thousand pounds
come off the airplane just like that
different missiles and different bombs
or whatever
the center of gravity of the airplane is
right about where my finger is
and so i have these weapons that are
here that when i release them it's
suddenly like dropping a car
off the front end of your airplane and
so there's a huge center of gravity
shift
that happens just like that and so the
flight controls need to be able to
compensate
for something like that last piece i'll
give you just for sake of time is what's
the speed envelope if you will that this
airplane kind of operates
oh i wish 200. man i wish 200. i would
buy one right now if i could go 200 in
this thing
yeah i mean on a good day right uh you
might get
you know if you get a really really high
end general aviation airplane
160 knots or so something like that you
can get more than that but then you
start getting into some real
like mercedes-benz exotic class kind of
general aviation airplanes that are like
the cirrus that go beyond there
in general you're talking somewhere
between 80 and about 140 150 for most of
them or something like that
this airplane believe it or not this
airplane can actually fly
as slow as the cessna but it also can
fly two times the speed of sound um and
it does that
pretty easily believe it or not um also
this airplane
60 degrees of bank starts to get really
extreme a little bit uncomfortable this
airplane
fully aerobatic doesn't care pulls nine
g's you guys know what g's are
the accelerations of gravity so
everything you know my human head well
mit mit heads weigh about 20 pounds or
so a little bit more than the
than the norm so at nine g's everything
on your body weighs nine times as much
so that's 180 pounds
with your neck has to be able to support
that imagine everything on this airplane
has to be stressed such that it can
tolerate that load
and more also can go negative g as well
altitude wise i think the highest i've
ever had a cessna
was about 14 000 feet and it was
wheezing
i mean it was really really hard for it
to get up there this airplane goes
zero feet all the way up to about 60 to
65 000 feet
so it flies twice as high of what you
would see on your commercial airliners
what i'm trying to impress on you is
it's a huge flight envelope
with a very different solution set
compared to what you might have on a
cessna the only other thing i would say
with raptor is this was something that
took me a while my first combat mission
i really understood this
in a cessna if i have a problem i can
land and
most likely people will come out to help
me and call home and let everybody know
i'm okay
in bad guy land if people are coming to
get me they really
are coming to get me uh so you're in
very hostile territory
where you do not want to leave the
airplane if you can avoid it
so there's a tremendous amount of
redundancy that's kind of built into
this airplane
we'll talk more through that a little
bit so anyway you've essentially derived
all of the challenges
that a flight control engineer would
have to deal with
uh let's talk a little bit about um
i'll put this here just for sake of
making it easy to rest
this airplane has what's called
reversible flight control system what
does that mean
you guys talked about that yet go ahead
tables or when you move you have to save
it directly
yep so not only when you move the stick
what happens if you go outside the
airplane grab the aileron move that up
and down what happens inside
the stick moves right so it's reversible
right so i move the stick
and the flight control surfaces will
deflect or i move the flight control
surfaces and the stick will deflect so
they are directly connected with pulleys
and cables to one another
um for the guys who have flown what does
the airplane feel like when you get to
120 130
140 miles an hour i mean you're really
getting what does it feel like on the
control surfaces
yeah a lot so it gets heavy right gets
real stick kind of heavy same thing if
you're slow
everything gets kind of sloppy if you
will and very because you are directly
feeling the air loads on the airplane as
transmitted to the stick
in this airplane these flight control
surfaces
this this tail surface back here is
about the size of a lot of fighter wings
it's huge um and you can imagine that
120 130 the airplane is
really hard to really move well what
happens if you're going 1 000
miles per hour you could be arnold
schwarzenegger you do not have the
strength
to maneuver these controls around so
this airplane has a very very exotic
hydraulic
system and a computer system and an
electric system that allows all that to
operate
from the hydraulics i'm not kidding
there's like 4 000
psi of hydraulic fluid that
moves this whole thing around swings it
back and forth
from the electric standpoint now again
this is a reversible flight control
system all manual
the flight controls in this airplane
don't work unless the electrics are
turned on
to go do it so your flight controls are
electrically controlled hydraulically
powered but electrically controlled
which is a little
weird when you think about it because
now all of a sudden
electrical problems in this airplane
start impacting your ability to fly
the airplane which gets a little bit
strange
you guys ever hear of a thing called a
permanent magnetic generator do you know
what that
is a little bit of a technical term who
knows
you know a lot go ahead is it effective
is it a type of generator that uses
permanent vacuuming
outstanding yes you have correctly
derived the definition of a permanent
magnetic generator now
the way it works is this airplane has
six permanent magnetic generators they
are the primary source of flight control
power
all that has to happen is the engines
have to rotate that's it
so even if the engines are shut down i
can just keep wind going through the
engines and they rotate they will rotate
sufficient to generate power
from the permanent magnetic generators
if those fail
the airplane also has electrical
generators on board there's two of them
there's actually three of them on board
they can power the flight controls as
well
worst case scenario for a raptor pilot
the engine seize up
i lose my electrical power the only
thing i have left is a battery
and just like anything else battery the
more you use it the more it depletes so
at that point any deflection of the
flight control surfaces
depletes the electrical energy and you
don't have that much left to actually
control it okay one last thing here
we'll move on to the next slide we'll
talk a little bit some
just some definitions um the wing has
this thing on the front you know what
that is what that's called leading edge
flaps right okay perfect all right
what's that called ailerons um
now what did i hear i heard something
else ah
who said that ah okay explain uh
it's a combination of both flap and
aoron um
flaps are on the outside under the
inside and
no they get that backwards yep all the
way around all the way around yep
and um depending on what you're doing a
flight you're in
either have full utils control surfaces
or
part of it is dedicated to the flash for
the part is dedicated to being the other
rounds
yeah standing that's good
in this airplane this airplane has what
ailerons right
so if i want to go right and i move the
yoke right what happens to the ailerons
here in this airplane sorry i'll put it
that way that way you're setting up so
i'm going this way
so this aileron is doing what it's going
um going down right this aileron is
doing a lot
up right um so i'll cut to the chase
these are ailerons these are fl so these
are the flapperons
here on the inside these are the
ailerons
in a raptor those ailerons deflect
differentially so just like you have
in a cessna they can also both deflect
up
they can also both deflect down the
flaps
on the inboard are flaps and ailerons
flapper ons so they can deflect
up and they can flect down we'll show
why that brings up some neat stuff
okay rudder obviously back here
in this airplane when i push the rudder
left the rudder deflects left i deflect
right
this has two rudders both rudders can
deflect one way they can deflect the
other way
they can both deflect in and there's
some reasons why you'd want to do that
and they can both deflect out
the last piece i'll give you is back
here normally this would be called an
elevator
but on a supersonic airplane we call
these horizontal stabilators
if you guys have read the story of the
bell x1 so chuck yeager
when he went supersonic we talked a
little bit earlier about supersonic
shock waves forming on the airplane as
you start going fast
what chuck yeager discovered is that the
elevator like in a traditional
cessna that horizontal stabilator does
not move
so the elevator at the back moves but
the horizon but it but this part stays
fixed
that shock wave that would form right
here would actually blank the air
back to the elevator and they wouldn't
have any pitch control
so when they talk about this thing
called mock tuck which was a scary scary
thing that happened to a lot of
world war ii fighter pilots when they
got into a dive
they would start forming shock waves on
the airplane they didn't have the
elevator authority to pull
up and so they would actually nose dive
all the way in because they go faster
and faster and faster heading down
the answer was rather than the back end
of this thing maneuvering
the entire surface moves so
as a fighter pilot especially when you
got people walking underneath the
airplane because their maintainers are
working on things
you always always always you show them
your hands because if you tap that stick
again the stick is not directly
connected just like it is the stick is
connected to a computer
the computer votes and allows things to
happen it then commands a 4000 hydraulic
psi system
to deflect basically this big old wing
you can actually take a guy's head off
with the flight control surfaces so you
always always show your hands whenever
you have people walking underneath the
airplane
for that so it's got a very very
advanced flight control system on board
we'll talk through a little bit about
what advantages that kind of gives you
last piece i'll give you is the engines
at the back
which are thing of beauty i was a
propulsion guy aeronautics engineer kind
of thing
it's almost like modern art masterpiece
to me those engines
are have the ability to call what's
called thrust vectoring they'll swing up
and they'll swing down where would you
want to use that
why does the why do the engines have
thrust vectoring you've answered a lot
man
you're smart though you know what's
going on go ahead very low speeds
very low speeds i'm standing yep where's
it where's another regime
think of the flight envelope of the
airplane
yeah very high very high altitude so so
why high altitudes
a little lift from the wings or the
wings can be
yeah density goes way down as you go up
in altitude
so if i deflect this i mean i have to
get more deflection to move that air
to be able to move the airplane if i'm
relying just on the aero surfaces alone
the way i get around that is i put two
35 000
thrust pound engines if you will on
board the airplane and just like a fire
hose if i grab a fire hose and i move it
you would feel that torque on your body
the same thing here with with the thrust
vectoring on the back
so with just the movement of my hand i
can deflect 70 000 pounds of thrust
way at the back end of the airplane so
we talked about center of gravity
being right about here so that moment
arm of that thrust force is
all the way back here and i can deflect
that up and at very very low speeds
where the flight control
surfaces might not be doing well i can
still move the airplane
just by using the the thrust alone at
high altitude where i don't have a lot
of density
same thing i can maneuver the airplane
just by using the thrust
alone so where that helps you because
again this is a dog fighter
here's what happens and you'll you'll
see this from time to time so i'll do
this with a side look
when i get to high angle of attack so
the wind is coming like this
and it's hitting the bottom surface of
the airplane um
i don't have the ability to really
maneuver a lot because sometimes some
air surfaces are blanked by just the
size of that fuselage
coming right out into the wing so i
cheat if you will by using the engines
to get that final little pitch rate
we'll see later on in the raptor demo
video
where the airplane will go it's called a
high alpha loop high angle of attack
loop
it'll go vertical and rather than doing
like a loop where you see it
prescribe this whole path over here the
airplane will go vertical
i'll engage the thrust vectoring and
it'll pivot so the velocity vector is
still heading straight up so the
airplane is still moving up
but it kind of does this gymnastics
thing where
i've now turned the airplane using
thrust vectoring even though the
airplane is still heading
straight up it's wacky it's totally cool
all right
all right let's talk through a couple
other things okay so that's the flight
controls
how we doing timeline okay we're looking
pretty good okay
okay anyone recognize the cockpit on
your left
f-15 yeah outstanding good this was my
very first airplane
i didn't know any better right i sat
down and said wow what a cool cockpit
look at all these cool stuff
buttons everywhere and switches all over
the place
this is an airplane of the 70s designed
when
richard nixon jimmy carter that kind of
era if you will
very very first intro to solid state
electronics really wasn't fully fleshed
out at this stage
um this airplane had a hydro mechanical
system which meant that just like in
this airplane where there are cables and
pulleys
the similar kind of flight control
system in it there
this picture is the raptors cockpit on
the inside
some pretty dramatic differences between
the two so again just call them out
what do you see
glass cockpit where does that help you
oh yeah it's great you see these new
digital cockpit
mercedes-benz and bmws or whatever where
like in the old days you just had you
know speed and tack if you will
now you can configure it however you
want um now these become
the moment you start putting that in
there no
got it yeah the moment you start doing
stuff like that you start creating a
software
airplane which gives you a lot of
flexibility and a danger right we'll
talk about that one a little bit later
on what else cc
flight control is why since we're
talking mainly about flight controls
today
side stick yeah so
right there is the control stick in an
f-15
sits directly between your knees in a
raptor
that is your control stick it's on the
side
why would you ever want to put something
like that on the side go ahead all right
you can't move your head that's part of
it that helps and there's actually you
can't see it here it's
partly there but kind of this little
section here it's a fold out armrest
so your wrist is on the stick your your
elbow is if you will it's resting on an
armrest so it gives you a lot of
leverage from there
um that's one reason what's a couple
other reasons why you'd want to go side
stick vice to center stick
your legs the way on the finish legs get
in the way that's a big deal
um because in this airplane you actually
got got pretty good after a while flying
it where if you really need to maneuver
the stick you kind of do the leg up and
kind of move over that way to get
everything out of the way um the other
side about it too it might not be quite
so obvious but you see how that stick
that's about where your eye height would
be um you see how that stick kind of
gets in the way of seeing some of the
instruments
so it's just sitting right there right
in a side stick that's completely off to
the side and
all of this real estate is completely
open
the other thing i'll give you again just
for sake of time it's it's a little bit
of a
thought change when you have a center
stick
it's like when you're driving a car and
when you're at
parking you know you're trying to park
your car you want to be able to maneuver
that wheel
around a lot uh but when you're at
highway speeds if you were to take the
wheel and
maneuver it that much again you're going
to roll the car
so in a center stick you
move the stick around to be able to
deflect the flight control surfaces
there's a physical displacement of the
stick to make that happen
on a side stick that stick initially
when they first put it in
did not move at all so imagine if you
were in your car and you wanted to steer
and rather than the wheel actually
moving you just put pressure
on the wheel itself and that was enough
to transmit to the computer in the car
to turn the wheels
that was a problem initially which we
can talk about after the presentation
that's a little bit of a sidebar
discussion
this is a human factors thing it's a
side stick
initially it didn't move eventually they
decided i'll put in some deflection so i
can go a half inch left a half inch
right
about a quarter inch forward because
normally uh
you know i go about a half inch back
because normally i really want to get
the nose going this way
if i had that much deflection forward i
don't want to fly the airplane this way
so you have the ability to do that but
it gives you a little bit of the best of
both worlds there's some deflection
to give you feedback that you've input
something on the stick
but not so much deflection that it kind
of gets in the way of everything else
you're trying to do so there's limited
real estate in a fighter cop pit
the last piece i'll give you and it's a
little bit hard to see here is
all those buttons there on the stick
you know what you have the ability to do
so it's
exactly like modern car car steering
wheels right now
you can control volume radio everything
else like that you can do it from the
steering wheel
same thing in a fighter it's called
hands-on throttle and stick hotas
and it allows you to control everything
that you would want to do on the
airplane with
never having to leave your your hands
from the throttle on the stick
the other piece i'll give you is that in
a raptor so in a fighter
like this this is your stick this is
your throttle in a raptor because the
flight control modes can change so much
this is your right inceptor and this is
your left
inceptor it's all considered part of the
flight control system
all right let's keep going so
just like on your car where if you want
to go to xm radio you go to media
source or whatever and go xm satellite
radio
you have buttons because it's a software
driven jet just like we saw before
and i can pull up a flight control
display that shows me the position of
all my flight control surfaces
again the pilot is way forward on the
front end of this airplane as i deflect
things sometimes i can't actually see
them
and so initially this was a flight test
display so that i don't have to do the
old poltergeist thing and try to rotate
all the way around to be able to see
to the back end of the airplane to see
if the elevator is moving
i basically instrument everything and i
can see it here now
some of the human factor stuff that's
kind of cool with how they did this
so this right here so again this tells
you at the top
rudder deflection surfaces ailerons
where the horizontal stabilators are at
how the engines are doing this is a
little weird i don't really like how
they did this one but this is the
leading edge flaps le flaps are 18 inch
flaps so it just shows you how far
they're deflected dug in dug down on the
lower left hand corner it shows you
center of gravity
so there's limits just like would you
you know what you would normally do on
flight planning for your cessna
hey i can only put this much fuel with
this much passengers and i got to be
within this limit for takeoff for
landing and everything else
the airplane tells you that now what's
cool about some of the things they've
done in raptor is that if it's out of
limits
again it doesn't expect you to get out
the piece of paper with the whiz wheel
and the e6b it just changes color
and it goes red and it gives you a
warning right and it says hey
idiot you are beyond the aft center of
gravity
no gauge tells you it's just having a
hard time seeing where all the fuel is
and everything else that's a different
story
but it tells you where what percentage
of mean aerodynamic cord that you're
sitting at
and it's able to adjust stuff around so
i'll give that to you because what this
allows is oh by the way the last part
here is flight control so in other words
this tells you
where you've moved your stick and it
tells you trim so you know where the
trim is set and also tells you where the
stick is set so you know your inputs
that kind of go through there when you
have a software driven
machine you can customize things and
make it very simple
you guys have seen that terrible
terrible awful movie top gun right
it's just awful right so that scene
where maverick loses his engines
and they go through this engine one is
out engine two is out and they go on
this flat spin
to sea which is a bunch of bs when
you're in a spin you don't
translate over the ground you fall
straight down so this whole flying out
to sea thing is ridiculous
it doesn't happen that way um in
if you don't have a software driven
airplane when you lose engines like that
then you've got to go through this whole
it's like
for instance in the cessna if you lose a
motor lose the motor
what do you got to do right establish
your glide get everything set up check
to see in my left right or both on the
fuel source what's my whatever blah blah
blah and everything else
in the raptor it's the most awesome
thing possible you literally do
nothing you sit there and the computer
goes oh you've lost the motor i've
noticed
that you have a problem let me see if i
can help you and it will restart the
motor for you
if it can right if it can't restart the
motor chances are it ain't going to
restart and you can just leave it
shut down if you will it allows some
neat human factor designs
because in this airplane in the raptor
believe it or not when you're flying the
raptor you're not
thinking about flying the raptor you're
thinking about employing the raptor so
you're trying to find where all of your
wingmates are
where the bad guys are etc etc flying
is secondary whereas in this plane
flying is everything
so they tried to as much as possible
alleviate the pilot from as much
burden of responsibility of thinking
about flying the airplane by doing kind
of neat little tricks like that
the other thing i'll give you too about
the flight controls is again we talked
about how
ailerons can go up ailerons can come
down flaparons go up
they go down rudders come out go down on
takeoff mode
i'll show you something kind of cool so
here's the nose
look on here on takeoff mode without any
input from the pilot so there's no flap
switch
in the cockpit there's no leading edge
there's nothing there's nothing like
that
it just knows based on the fact that
you've got the gear handle down
and that you're on the ground and it
senses the weight on wheels that thinks
this guy wants to take off
so the rudders will both deflect inward
why would you do that god
so that needs a shorter runway so um
not quite um there is a tie between the
flight controls though so in other words
if i take the rudders and i
tow them both in so both rudders are
deflected in
what does that do from an aerodynamic
standpoint
which way is the nose going to go if
these rudders are deflected in
up right so it makes it easier to rotate
the airplane on takeoff because the
rudders are deflecting
in both of them go in right the other
part about it too
is so we talked about this you guys ever
see like a competition aerobatic like
one of those extra 300 kind of airplanes
see how the aileron runs the entire
length of the whole wing
so about the pilot all they got to do is
just tap the wing and the airplane is
going to do
corkscrews and spirals on a raptor
that's part of the reason why the
aileron and the flapper on can move
together as one
surface and so the leading edge flaps
will dig in
the trailing aileron and the chilling
edge flap that will dig in as well
so on takeoff with no input from the
pilot
whereas the wing normally would look
sort of like this with a little bit of
camber
on it on takeoff the wing looks like
this
it's kind of cool like when you look at
it from the side so if you're looking at
it from
directly side on that leading edge flap
comes down these come down
that puts in a whole bunch of camber on
the wing
and it generates a lot of lift so and
again that's completely independent of
the pilot the pilot has done nothing
other than just tell it i'm on the
ground because the gear handle
is down last what's what would be what
would be a typical rotation speed
yeah so that's a good question what do
you guys think
so i start on the runway by the way i
need 8 000 feet of runway this whole
2500 feet is
not for a raptor unfortunately um 8 000
feet of runway but by the time i
actually get ready to pull back on that
stick to rotate
um how fast you think it's going
i wish well close
150 is a usual usually so about takeoff
weights by the way this airplane is
about
34 or 35 tons on takeoff compared to
like you know
2500 pounds or whatever
so it's a very heavy airplane it's got
to get a lot of speed to be able to get
that
rotation that's about 150 160 knots uh
on takeoff which is
like faster than like the never exceed
speed of the cessna
as it goes um but yeah so the flight
controls are there to help you
um the other thing i'll show you too is
uh there is so
sail plane guys where are my cell plane
guys fly sail planes
so on the left in a cell plane copper
you typically have a lever for
the speed brakes spoilers right so these
big surfaces that pop up on the wing
to slow the airplane down adjust glide
slopes and those sorts of things
we talked a little bit earlier about how
the electrical engineer guys want this
thing to be completely stealthy and
whatever else
the last thing you want to do based on
the discussion we just had
is i don't want to have a big board
stick up in the middle of this airplane
because that's going to make my radar
reflection go very very large
so they did something kind of remarkable
they use the flight control surfaces
themselves as the speed brakes
so if i need to slow the airplane down i
hit a little switch on the throttle
and immediately what happens is the
leading edge flaps will
come down a bit the ailerons will both
go up
the rudders will go out so they'll both
toe out
and it's using that to help slow the
airplane kind of down it's actually
quite effective
which is pretty cool all right a couple
other things we'll go through
landing mode pilots done nothing
touchdown throttles are back gear
handles down
and all of this stuff happens here let
me get this zoomed in here
so that's the aileron it's up holy crap
the other one's up too the flapper on
goes up on either side
um the rudders you can see how they're
both kind of kind of towing in there a
little bit
the reason it's doing that is it's
trying to transfer all of that weight
from the wings and put it into the gear
so it's trying to kill
all of the lift on the wings and
transfer that to the landing gear so
that you have the maximum
traction on the wheels as you hit the
brakes as you slow down
also on refueling
so when you go air refueling there's a
little switch
that you open in the jet that opens up
this door that tells the jet that i'm
getting ready to refuel
while i'm airborne when it does that it
says this guy isn't trying to dogfight
the airplane anymore
they're trying to get gas so therefore i
don't need all the full
roll capability and everything else and
really what i really want is an airplane
that's really responsive with its lift
and so again no input from the pilot but
the leading edge
flaps will deploy down the trailing edge
flaps and the ailerons will also deploy
down again they're trying to create
camber
on that wing this is all digital flight
controls no input from the pilot
whatsoever
what would a typical airspeed be when uh
doing this air refueling
uh this is about whoops i'm sorry let me
go back one here
this is about uh about 300 300 knots or
so something like that
um you got to be able to fly so for a
raptor that's kind of slow
um for the tanker airplane that's
somewhat fast
so you're trying to find that marriage
where both airplanes have good flying
qualities
so that one's not about to stall and the
other one's in full power trying to
catch up to them
by the way the most unnatural act i've
ever done as a fighter pilot is to
connect up my airplane to another
airplane
i just never got used to it i can do it
just fine but the whole notion of
this big boom connecting my airplane to
the big airliner was just really strange
and weird to me
never got used to it okay some of the
limiters
so in an f-15 because we
talked to that a little bit earlier f-15
can you can get up to 500
600 miles an hour you can take both
hands on the stick you can pull that
stick all the way back
and you will rip the wings off the
airplane and you will turn it into a big
ball of metal cascading down to the
ground
because you have overjeed the airplane
again that awful terrible movie top gun
in which tom cruise departs the airplane
and gets into a spin
again you've exceeded some capability of
the airplane and the airplane departs
controlled flight and gets into some
type of uncontrolled situation
on a raptor there used to be in the
pilot operating manual a little blurb
that said
quote you can maneuver this airplane
with quote
reckless abandon and you will not over g
the airplane
you will not depart the airplane from
controlled flight they did a
spectacular job uh allowing this
airplane to get
right to the edge of performance but not
going over the top
so one of the neat things that they did
airplanes in a left-hand turn look at
that aileron it's up
look at that aileron it's up
what the crap is going on there
and if you know this one you really do
get the model
because i didn't know this for a long
time
so again just for sake of times i know
we got guys coming in afterwards
center of gravity the airplane sits
right here
in your engineering classes you always
talk about forces acting on the center
of gravity and you kind of take this
whole airplane and you model it down to
a point mass
and you say that's what that's you know
for sake of all the the
you know sum of forces analysis well in
real life
this is about 43 feet wide
yeah you can sum the forces through
there but there's forces acting all over
this airplane
at different spots think about here on
the wingtip
i put g on the airplane and this wing
tip it's almost like the wings want to
bend
up right as i'm coming down so you put a
lot of stress
out on the wingtips so their answer
quite ingeniously
was to deflect the ailerons down when
you're at high maneuvering
the way you know you're at high
maneuvering is you can kind of see these
little wispies forming off the wingtips
so you are creating low pressure that's
another one too you can see the clouds
forming on the front edge of the wing
low pressure causes that air to condense
and so you make clouds so you know the
airplane is really maneuvering up
and an answer to reduce stress at the
wing tips
was to deflect the ailerons up what
happens to the lift out of the wing tips
with the ailerons up
goes down right so it helps to kind of
push those wings back down again
so you're not trying to over stress the
airplane there are limiters
like this all over the airplane such
that you won't over g the airplane you
can't
you know literally you can do anything
you want to this airplane that's why i'm
telling you it's easier to fly a raptor
than it is to fly a cessna
because you really have to pay attention
what you're doing in a cessna in a
raptor
i could put my kid in there and he can
do this all day at whatever speed and
nothing bad will happen to the airplane
it's really quite spectacular
how they did that uh the other part i'll
give you here is some of the command
systems
so if i'm in a dogfight and i'm trying
to shoot the other guy
i'm going against a maneuvering target
and so the flight controls
transfer over to what's called a g
command system
so if i'm maneuvering at four g's and i
let go of the stick the airplane
will stay at four g's and if i see that
the target's maneuvering i need to go to
six g's or seven g's i'll put that in
and the airplane will keep that so in
other words
again it's a vote right i'm not
physically connected to anything i talk
to the computer and i say i want six gs
and the airplane does all types of black
magic and sorcery behind me
and lo and behold the airplane gets to
six to seven g's
that really matters when you're in a
high maneuvering kind of situation so it
goes g
command when you're slower i.e
on landing and i want to put that flight
path marker
right on that edge of the runway because
that's where i want to touch down right
at the thousand foot markers
then in that scenario i'm not really
cared so much about g command i care
about
pitch rate and so it transitions over to
a pitch rate command
and if i put no input on the stick it
says zero pitch rate
again blackmagic and sorcerer will
happen behind me the flight controls
will do whatever they need to do
to make sure that my pitch rate stays at
zero so it transitions from one type of
flight control system to the other no
pilot input whatsoever it's just based
off a flight
flight command system all right so let's
talk through a couple of the
implications of that and then we'll go
to questions at the end
can you do the flight control video
raptor at the top it's about a minute
and then bring it up to full screen and
hit pause
thank you okay this one is uh full
screened and pause
okay and can you go back to the
beginning on it real quick
okay so video in cockpit facing out the
display screens is a big no-no
because you could see stuff so we won't
even bother with that but what they did
this is the raptor flight demonstration
team this is out of
langley air force base virginia they
mounted a camera in the cockpit kind of
facing aft
what i love about this is again you can
see real quick
kind of what's going on with the
airplane so again the leading edge slats
there's no
input from the pilot other than just
maneuvering they'll deploy wherever they
need to
you'll see the horizontal stabilizators
and if you're close you can actually see
where the ailerons are doing and what
the flaperons are doing
a neat trick and we'll see this as they
go into this high g
demo you guys know about have you this
gets a little bit advanced but a thing
called static margin
which is a stability thing about this
airplane again this airplane in its bare
airframe configuration
no hydraulics no computers nothing on
board the airplane
totally unstable what keeps it stable is
the computer itself
what you'll see is you'll see this
maneuver where he'll go into a g-turn
and you'll see all the clouds forming on
the back end of the airplane
pay attention to what the leading edge
flaps are doing they're digging in
the horizontal stabilizators you'll see
them initially move to get the turn
going
but then once established in the turn
the way it's controlling things is it's
moving around the aerodynamic center and
this
the center of gravity it's doing that by
dorking around a bit with the lift on
the wing and it's doing that by
deflecting the leading edge flaps
so that flight control surface display i
showed you earlier the horizontal
stabilizers will be completely
streamlined
and all of the maneuvering is coming
from the wing itself
which is pretty amazing the next video
no no
go to flight controls we'll watch that
i'll go back okay yep and then we'll
just kind of watch as it goes through
this time without the funky club music i
guess hopefully
[Music]
horizontal stability
[Music]
i know totally
so at that speed again it's a g command
system pilot is commanding a certain
g-rate
and minor deflections are happening all
the way here back along the back edge of
the airplane pilots has no input on that
the system is doing everything possible
to command that g that the pilot has
asked for
you'll see one other maneuver here pause
for a second
so what this maneuver is is and again
right
slow speed um airplanes going straight
up
and what they're trying to do is
basically pitch forward completely
um and get the airplane so it's almost
like you're flying an l like you're
going straight up
and then you want to pitch forward and
then accelerate out horizontally that
way
the way it gets that is through that
that thrust vectoring that happens but
as that maneuver happens again all the
pilot is doing it just doing a direct
push forward on the stick
watch what happens to all the flight
controls in the back of the airplane
to keep that airplane going exactly
where the air pilot wants it to play
so you'll see huge deflections out of
that horizontal stabilator
it's kind of neat you can keep playing
so what you're seeing there is um from
the outside of the airplane we'll see
this more on the
demo is the airplane is essentially
pirouetting
in the sky so it's falling straight down
but it's very controllable it's flying
at speeds about 60 to 65 miles an hour
but very very controllable and you'll
see every bit of flight control surface
on the back end of this airplane
deflecting to do what it needs to do
so don't think of it in terms of aileron
elevator
it's a little bit fluid when it comes to
a raptor it's stuff
stuff happens back there touch and go
video okay so this shows a little bit of
yeah you can go ahead and play that
and hit pause for a second we'll just do
this setup
okay so very quick the setup for this
video um
this is the downside of a digital flight
control system
uh because on this airplane again it's
it's pure cables pulleys right it's
ratios and gears and
stuff like that right on this airplane
it's software code it's
zeros and ones and you better get it
right and
everything is interconnected we talked
about how moving the gear handle tells
the flight control system something
different if i open the air refueling
door
it tells the flight control something
different in this case
the power setting of the airplane tells
the airplane
something different this guy one of my
good friends
test pilot outstanding guy so don't
think of this as he's a bad pilot he's
not he's
awesome but the jet believed something
that wasn't really true because there
was an error in how the software was
coded
and you'll see the first approach he'll
do an approach he'll take off again
what's called military power so they're
not using afterburner
and the airplane behaves just fine on
the next time around he
goes around using afterburner power so
you'll see fire come out of the back end
of the airplane
and that changes something in the flight
system for the
engines which tells the flight control
computer a different condition
and what ended up happening is that the
gains if you will of the stick were
completely
off so again this would be like if you
were on the highway speed and that same
wheel deflection you would use to park
your car in your garage
now that little deflection of your wheel
makes that same turn of the tires up
front
so you get into what's called a pilot
induced oscillation pio
which basically says you're out of phase
with the airplane if i'm driving my car
and i turn the steering wheel right the
car's going left
as it's going left i'm trying to correct
that i go right now the thing goes right
and so you get out of phase with the
airplane
and you'll see what happens go ahead and
play by the way you see all the flight
control surfaces deflecting in the back
this is now in a pitch rate system so
he's just trying to land the airplane
the back of the airplane does whatever
it needs to do to keep that flight path
marker exactly where it needs to go
and again all the flight control
surfaces deflected military power
because the engines are black if you
will on this one
on the next time around you'll see him
maneuver with afterburner
and you'll see him get into this pitch
induced oscillation
that's the chase airplane by the way
it's an f-16 that follows them around
so same thing getting set up to land the
camera goes out of focus here for a
second comes back in
again just notice everything that's
happening on the back end of this
airplane
to keep that pitch rate where the pilot
has commanded it to
two things will happen here he selects
afterburner and he raises the gear that
changes the flight control laws
and the gains were not set correctly
there's the afterburner and now you see
where he's out of phase with the
airplane and he's doing everything to
keep the airplane from hitting the
ground
and can't avoid it
he's okay
but the airplane was fairly well scraped
up you can imagine so it's just a danger
right
the digital flight controls allow a lot
of flexibility and creativity
there used to be a term it's only
software you know we can figure it out
not true when you're dealing with you
know
vehicles like this where small changes
in software code can have dramatic
implications on the ability of the
airplane so
it takes an amazing amount of uh demo
yep you can go into raptor demo and with
that we can go questions because i'm a
little bit over
no that's fine okay so we can play this
full speed or uh full full screen if you
will
you want to take questions while it's
running yeah so this is from another
good buddy of mine guy named
zeke skelicki who was the raptor demo
pilot outstanding guy
but this is the raptor demo if you've
ever seen it so we'll take some
questions while this is gone go ahead
yeah greater than one to one so the
airplane about sixty three sixty four
thousand pounds
uh normally a strong takeoff the thrust
coming out the back is 70 000 pounds
so on a nice cold day like if you're
close enough to sea level
you will actually go faster than the
speed of sound while you're climbing
up which is cool
oh yeah try to repeat the question if
you can oh sorry because he's not miked
so the question was uh well one the
question was is thrust weight ratio um
it's greater than one to one a little
bit greater than one to one uh on
takeoff
by the way watch this maneuver here real
quick so that's the thrust vectoring
um kind of kicking in to really get the
airplane so initially that's the flight
control surfaces and then as things
slow down the thrust vectoring kicks in
to basically turn the airplane into a
flat plate
second question was about the thrust
vectoring on take off
so it'll put in a little bit up not much
just a little bit up just to help the
nose rotate but
just just a tad this is that high angle
of attack
uh kind of maneuver if you will
keep going it's all good questions yeah
you said all the software's written so
basically so the plane can't damage
itself yeah does the pilot become one of
them
and it's just human situations where it
can hurt you yeah
very much so in fact we've kind of
achieved that spot now where the pilot
very much is limiting the performance of
the airplane itself because the airplane
can do
so much more um what you so this is
what's called a fifth generation
fighter first generation was like an old
korean war
like f-86 kind of airplane and then
successively through the generations
you arrive at this fifth generation
which to me is the pinnacle of what you
could get with a human
and an airplane together sixth
generation is going to involve
teaming this airplane with unmanned
airplanes and the unmanned airplanes are
going to have
a lot more capability from a maneuvering
standpoint because they don't have the
limitation of the pilot and all the life
support systems that come with it and
everything else so
all that weight you would normally
devote to that you can get away with
putting other stuff in there
when i was telling you it flies about
the same speed as like cessna
i mean this is those types of maneuvers
there where you can get away with that
again watch the flight control surfaces
in the back and what's going on
later on they'll do a pass where he'll
open up the doors and you can see the
main weapon bay which is underneath the
airplane belly and then you'll see the
side weapon bay doors
so you can kind of see kind of where all
the weapons are carried inside the
airplane
again a huge center of gravity challenge
incidentally so so here's that maneuver
so you can see the doors open
one thing i didn't really tell you about
is so in that situation because you know
missiles weigh a couple hundred pounds a
piece or so some of the bombs are about
a thousand pounds a piece when you lose
all that weight immediately it's
literally like dropping a car
off the front end of your airplane the
way that it fixes that center of gravity
issue is by changing fuel
inside the airplane so it sloshes fuel
forward or back to keep the center of
gravity
again completely pilot there's no fuel
control panel where i go we'll move this
and click this and whatever
it does it all completely automatically
go ahead yeah
the sensors that you can use so all of
the fuel tanks are are instrumented
um so you know the status of fuel in
terms of where things are
set up um it you tell it what actually
it has the ability to know what's on the
airplane so when you load a missile it
goes oh it's this type of missile and it
goes
it weighs this much and it knows the
mass properties of it and so it sets it
up
from there um so
it actually identifies that all by
itself so like in a
in a cirrus you have to go you have to
actually pull up a screen in the cirrus
and go
my passenger weighs this and i've got
this baggage on board
and then it gives you the picture of
where the center of gravity is
this thing because it's all digital the
missile has a little connector rod that
connects in and it says
ah behold i'm a missile oh the pilot
weight doesn't matter
uh because they they they expect it uh
well
it matters but for a different reason um
it matters for the ejection seat
predominantly because the ejection seat
um you know i think it's like 135
pounds is the light it's something like
that 115 135
to like 220 or something it's something
around that spot
um so to be able to be within the safe
envelope of the ejection seat
that's where the weight of the pilot
matters um
but they they spec the center of gravity
such that so long as
really anyone can sit up front and
you're not going to throw off the cg of
the airplane
even though you're way far forward of
the of the cg and there
there's a moment arm there but between
everything else in the cockpit i mean
that ejection seat is ridiculously heavy
and all the avionics that sit up front
the radars up front i mean all these
things that sit up there
have far more of a contribution to the
center of gravity than you do
unless you're like shaq or something
like that but god
so in this airplane not yet uh that's
coming along soon some of the older
airplanes believe it or not have that
like the f-15 that i flew you had a
special helmet
that had all of the information
displayed on the visor itself
so in addition to that hands-on throttle
and stick so i don't have to take my
hands off of anything to touch anything
in the cockpit
i also don't have to look in the cockpit
to see altitude
air speed heading it's all displayed to
me
up front this airplane eventually will
get that it it didn't make the
this is a programmatic discussion now
right they only had so many dollars to
spend and they said this airplane is so
awesome
that it shouldn't need a helmet mounted
display system because it should be able
to see
all the bad guys from far enough away
and not be a problem we fielded the
airplane that way and every pilot
you so the first batch of pilots they
all transitioned from
airplanes that had that helmet mounted
system and they came to this airplane
where it didn't have it
and they were pissed they're like we got
to have that back right so that's kind
of where a lot of the efforts now are
going to modernize the airplane a bit
what else good questions go ahead yeah
yeah uh
it is it is the great debate of the
fighter community right now
and you're really touching on something
really really deep um
the best answer so far is that
the greatest i mean we talked a lot
about the hardware and the systems on
board the airplane
really the greatest piece of capability
on the airplane is the mind of the
person
flying up front if it's a very dynamic
and changing
environment to be able to tell a machine
to be able to incorporate all those
inputs and make the right decisions
based on that
kind of hard to do right now i'm not
saying we're not going to get there just
right now it's
it's difficult where we use unmanned
systems a lot now is like
in surveillance missions where you can
just launch the thing and it's got a
pre-programmed navigation and it knows
what it needs to do and it can
set things up those are somewhat bounded
problems
probably the best way to describe it
where you could use an unmanned system
for that
work it's difficult is in combat
situation it's it's extremely dynamic
it's
it's battle royale wwf mosh pit
any possible chaotic situation you can
put that's kind of what it looks like
and so having a human mind attached in
that environment to be able to adapt
and do what the mind does better than a
machine does at least right now that's
the main argument
to keep humans in the system for now
right
there's a follow-up on that
not yeah to remotely operate them yes
it is um
yeah the question is is that if you
operate these things remotely
so even if you had so you know classic
example we'll use sully sullenberger
right as because we talked about sully
in the previous one
you take off out of laguardia you lose
both engines if you could have a remote
pilot
sitting somewhere else that could take
over and decide land on the hudson
because a machine
most likely wouldn't have made that
choice is there a time lag
issue the answer is 100 yes there is a
time lag issue between
getting that information displayed down
make the input that input goes back up
and comes back over
a thing we've done at test pilot school
is remember we showed earlier that
flight path marker uh
where as a pilot you put the flight path
marker and that's exactly where your
airplane's going to go
if there's a time lag that will actually
mess you up because there's some second
or two delay between what you're seeing
and what the airplane's actually going
at test pilot school they actually built
a flight test or flight path marker
that accounts for that time delay if it
knows that time delay it'll actually
account for it
so you could fly the airplane remotely
even with the time lag and still be able
to do very high gain tasks like land the
airplane for instance
where things are changing very rapidly
so it's a new science
not fully fleshed out here but the proof
of concept has been demonstrated
to control an airplane remotely even
with the time lag
who really cares about that right now
are the airlines because
uh to be very frank uh the pilots tend
to be a pain in the butt for an airline
company
and if you can remove the pilots and
just have a remote operated system or
even an autonomous system
uh to the from a business standpoint the
company really likes that from an
aviation standpoint
it triggers all types of discussions and
a lot of other issues
but that's one question good let me jump
let me jump in for a minute with that i
think
actually to me one of the holy grails of
ga safety
would be to have uh a
human co-pilot perhaps you know on the
ground
so if you had that kind of telemetry
that you have in a in a drone
uh you know human somewhere else could
say you know you're running a little
short on fuel or you forgot to change
tanks all the things that a human
co-pilot could do right in the cockpit
you know most of that safety running
checklists could be probably enhanced
remotely so that would be a great add to
a cessna or a piper even
and you see a little bit now in some of
the more advanced airplanes like we
talked a little bit about if i have an
engine problem in the raptor i literally
do nothing i just sit there and stare at
the clouds and go wow what a lovely day
and look the computer
fixes it for me right there are other
scenarios where the
jet will tell me hey you've got a
generator problem and then immediately
pull up the checklist
for the generator failure to allow me to
fix it so you see
some basic automation right now kind of
already in play a couple other questions
i know we're running short guys
how much a flying raptor is seated that
you would miss by not being
in cockpit by not being there so
automated at this point that it's the
same whether you're sitting there or
yeah if it's a uh so it's we have two
terms one's called beyond visual range
which means i can't see the other guy
with my eyes
but my sensors can see him um and if i'm
shooting missiles
long distance like that i don't lose any
seat of the pants by being remotely
it's like a video game like literally
it's exactly like a video game
um if it's a maneuvering environment
where i see the guy and we're in a
dogfight then yeah you lose a lot
right in terms of seat of the pants
eyeball just things that are hard to
to automate so it's half and half right
in a drone scenario i mean
would a drone dog fight i don't know
it's a good question i'm not
really sure god to address that could
you just have
a simulator remotely
you could um but then i have to have
some way to represent
the physical environment that the drone
is seeing i got to be able to represent
that to
the guy in the simulator on the ground i
have to be able to kind of relay that
real time
um it matters so uh
who plays sports right guys you know any
i mean whenever you're playing sports
you got an opponent
uh you get if you play a lot like if
it's racquetball or football or
something like that you get very good at
looking at your opponent and being able
to see micro movements before
the actual big movement happens so that
you know oh they're about to swing this
way or they're going to throw this way
so you can
read your opponent and make a decision
about what's about to happen a second or
two from now
in a fighter jet the exact same thing if
i'm fighting a guy
and i see a control surface deflection
even before the airplane is gone i know
person's going this way i can position
myself to be there before they arrive
i would need some way to represent that
if i'm in a simulator
on the ground and it would have to be
kind of transparent to the guy in the
simulator
what that feels like
lots of good questions it's a good class
let me ask actually where's
who's here from the flying club uh
sebastian yeah yeah
actually i wonder if les can you stay
another uh 10 15 minutes absolutely why
don't we have sebastian jump in
give us flying club spiel and then uh
both of them will be up front for uh
questions right afterwards thank you liz
[Applause]
you